le cdas 9 5 atv le département de la
réunion vous présente le 13e concours de
calcul rapide bonjour à tous propose de
démarrer ce jeu rapide je vais d'abord
voir comment ça va fonctionner il va y
avoir deux premières parties passé de
3,4 à vide pour les riverains du port à
2 de l'ailé fut un temps de réflexion
que dix secondes maximum
ensuite ils ont à la série de trois
problèmes
on est vraiment pour des notes et il
aura seconde main sur vos réflexions
vous pouvez peser à tout moment dès que
vous avez
ne vous présentez ce n'est donc on va
commencer par la première partie c'est
dire calcul automatisés vous avez trois
calcul
je commence par le premier 726 +39 726
+39
deuxième calcul 150 x 650 x 6 3e calcul
quel est le corps de 840 alors on peut
avoir un petit peu le score le alors on
va donc continuer n'a rien n'est perdu
on va continuer sur la deuxième partie
c'est à dire calcul réfléchi voilà et
donc voilà vous pouvez prendre des notes
pour les calculs un facteur or antoine
et avec 68 lettre à distribuer dans le
premier immeuble
il en a distribué la moitié et 30 dans
le deuxième immeuble
combien de lettres lui reste de thil à
distribuer
c'est la bonne réponse passe au deuxième
les enfants se partagent à parts égales
les fruits qu'ils ont cueilli michel en
accueilli 25 paul 15
alain minc combien de fruits
or à chaque enfant les enfants se
partagent à parts égales les fruits qui
l'ont cueilli michel en accueilli 25
pour le 15
c'est le rendez vous alors le sort ce
niveau angie et julien troisième
problème on fête cette année le 75e
anniversaire de grand mère en quelle
année et elle n'est en fait cette année
le 75e anniversaire de grand mère en
quelle année est elle née
perso ce pas au nom du sport ce groupe
et à ce stade les paramètres nous
expliquer comment ça c'est vrai pour la
suite
nancy 16e se soucient guère des
conseillers première fois qu'une
première déçu 6e
le premier qui trouve la bonne réponse
regardez gagne la légende
si jamais parler de leurs problèmes ne
se suffisait pas c'est une nouvelle
naissance donne la moitié des 360 + du
jury
cette ville ne doit passer à la deuxième
manche quand celle de j p donc voilà il
a fait le coup et sans décote la
confiance sainte marie et la mort bon
alors si vous êtes prêt on va commencer
par le calcul de matinée vous avez trois
calcul renier calcul 500 - de son 9 506
de nouveau deuxième calcul 87 x 187
troisième calcul
quel est le double de 505
mais ici c'est la bande annonce
alors à ce stade on est le 3e salon
damien tu veux on croit égaliser en quoi
croire le problème d'accord alors
premier problème
david pèse 5 fois moins qu'un huitième
200 kg combien de kilos
david at il de plus que son copain qui
pèse 38 kg dames une belle cinq fois
moins que lui 2 200 kg combien de kilos
d'avis les pattes ils de plus que son
copain qui pèse 38 kg
c'est terminé la réponse est oui alors
je seek rapidement pourquoi dès les 16 6
fois moins d'une heure de son futur à se
dire ils baissent karachi - comme 40.5
garçons ont su ce que souvent 1,38 qui
aura comme david hess khartoum à 48 kg
la vitesse sera plus sous deuxième
problème pour l'anniversaire de marie sa
mère a prévu quatre bouteilles de 75
centilitres dessus elle remplit des ders
chaque verre contient 20 centilitres
combien de verres peut-elle remplir pour
l'anniversaire de marie sa mère a prévu
quatre bouteilles de 75 centilitres de
qu elle rend vie des vers chaque verre
contient 20 centilitres combien de verve
vettel randria
cette année personne fait la source de
ces problèmes la résidence fait en fait
donc la mairie à trégastel 75 centimes
pour les 4 x 60 km3 senti qu'on me taxe
à 300 ce qui pourra revenir maintenant
des verts qui font un souci donc une 306
la grèce fin en guyane 15h à ce
troisième volet alors le troisième ligne
et problème cette année l'association
cdas fête ses 33 ans en quelle année at
elle été créée cette année l'association
elle été créée
le troisième problème organiser 1983 ce
nom 2016 si la saison 3 en 2007 33 sa
famille le sentais à l'aise comme s'ils
voulaient beaucoup plus étroit qualifie
pour la prochaine et c'est un progrès on
va passer ou là pendant des décennies un
compte à la mangue et matières au palais
de vous présenter aujourd'hui mon
calepin
ainsi la confiance
on commence avec les trois calcul
automatisé premiers calculs 15,5 plus
12e 5 6 2e calcule combien d'une demi
heure
y at-il dans 6h30
c'est pas 6h30 il y en tout 13 mur y'a
de devenir gouverneur sanusi foetus est
la dernière
ceux-ci 13,2 alors entre parenthèses 83
- 33 x 11
alors donc on va passer dans la deuxième
partie calcul réfléchir vous pourrez
prendre des notes et on calcule une
caisse contient 20 boîtes de sardines
une boîte pèse 75 grammes et la caisse
vide pèse 250 g
quel est le poids en grammes de la
caisse plaignant une caisse contient
d'un mois 210 n'hésite alors pas ce
retard deuxième problème les as à 100
euros
elle achète 3 op valant le même bruit
il lui reste 16 euros après cet achat
quel est le fruit d'une poupée les ans à
100 euros
elle achète 3 poupée volant le même prix
il y reste
euros après cet achat alors le show ce
9e seuls trois films you mais nous reste
des problèmes tous les mercredis à
lèvres à la bibliothèque
ils mangent 900 m à l'aller et autant au
retour qu'elle tisse en sports - s'il en
kilomètres pendant quatre semaines
tous les maires ou eti allen à la
bibliothèque
ils marchent 900 m à l'aller et autant
retour elle distance par voici là ce
n'est pas la même ambiance
donc j'ai passé tous les mercredis alain
badiou tech que marche 900 m à l'aller
on retrouve ça veut dire l'euro 2008 son
rêve aller retour et en suisse il
c'est ce parcours en quatre semaines de
1810 par case on arrive à 7204 et comme
le demande la sanction des sexes et deux
passes
alors donc quand tu es est qualifiée
pour la seconde manche
bon passons
on passe maintenant la deuxième manche
donc on va appeler alex paraît de
l'école c'est la matinale cellules et
robin nil ou à l'école d'application
malviès à 2 10 alors vous allez vous
présenter
je suis et un sens du style alors
premiers calculs 73,8 - 43,6 deuxième
calcul ci s'en tape +86 +36 604 +86 plus
comme si ce troisième calcul donne lui
tiers de 7500 de lumière de 7500
existent ils me voient l'adresse à trois
points et panis alix fera se rattraper
encore un bus hier 3 au bled
alors on passe donc à la deuxième tandis
premier problème ou prennent des
notaires victo et ses trois amis ont
ensemble 75 chambres chacun de ses amis
en a 18 combien vitaux at il de timbres
vitaux et ses trois amis ont ensemble
75e chacun de ses amis en a 18 combien
ditto hâtif de timbres
c'est une non plus deuxième problème un
manchon récolte 400 kg de pommes de
terre
il vante quel sac de 10 kg et 20,5 de 5
kg quelle masse de pommes de terre lui
reste-t-il à vendre un manche en récolte
400 kg de pommes de terre
ils font qu'un sac de 10 kg
le dernier problème une agence de
voyages propose la découverte une île
pour 1200 30 euros pour deux personnes
pendant cinq jours combien doit payer
chaque personne une agence de voyages
propose la découverte d'une île 2002 130
euros à deux personnes pendant cinq
jours et nous pensons donc on va passer
maintenant mener au cm2 on appelle les
deux premiers candidats
mignot beau score de l'école beau 1505
petit et mézino thomas de l'école
evariste de parny de sa mère on est
alors on va commencer par les croire
calcul automatisés
ollier calculs 30 x 21 2e calcul 999
points 75 + 13,25 me fais troisième
calcul entre parenthèses 1375 -265
divisé par dix
c'est normalement prendre fin la semaine
alors on va passer maintenant aucun but
de réfléchir ou pour y prendre des notes
le premier problème un antiproton 185
euros suivi une réduction de 50%
quel est son nouveau prix 99 ans
deuxième problème
un escargot a parcouru une distance de
7,1 m en 6 minutes calcule la distance
moyenne parcourue en une minute
un escargot pas parcouru une distance de
sept médecins ensuite
eh bien le troisième problème va vous
départager dans le périmètre de
rectangle est égal à 120 m sa longueur
est de taille m
combien mes yeux sa largeur se reprend
pas sûr qu'elle se souvienne pour rappel
massif c'est le premier rideau ne se
soucient guère qui remporte la partie
d'accord on peut pas prendre le dessus
sur un espace donne le camp de 164 cas
donc demandé au final alors donc oscars
seront ils demain
3 - dans l'océan finale pour rappeler
les deux autres candidats de cm2
stéphane charles de l'école catholique
sainte clotilde et web et théophile de
l'école jeanne nativel de l'étang salé
alors charles kaboré a reproduit calcul
567 divisé pensée 567 / cette deuxième
calcul 113,7 - 14,4
4/10 de seconde mort troisième calcul
entre parenthèses 993 plus douce
multiplié par dix entre parenthèses 993
points 12 x 10 puisque partout et fils
donc on va passer maintenant problème et
vous prétendez not only problème une
cuillère contient cinq mille litres de
sirop le médecin prescrit un flacon de
200 millilitres pour 4 cuillères en jour
combien de temps dure le traitement dix
jours
deuxième problème
un cycliste et un trajet de 45 km dont
les deux tiers sont en montée et le
reste en descente
quelle est la longueur de la descente 15
mai alors parce qu'au dernier problème
un rectangle apollo 8 m
sa longueur est le triple de sa largeur
quel est son air en maître par et eric
thomas brasch lui m sa longueur et le
triple de sa largeur
quel est son année rome et paris 192 m
c'est leur donner les noms alors il dit
ok bon alors maintenant on va passer à
la finale c'est dire que la grande
finale la finale d'essayer d'abord
ensuite offert à la finale de cm heures
et après la finale de scène de la
supports culturels
alors on va appeler cabot julienne et
boyer coloris donc voilà les deux
finalistes est rien on l'a donc
maintenant on n'est qu'à la finale
c'est à dire celui ou celle qui rêvait
lié sera le champion la championne
niveau ces deux boîtes toutes les
réunions d'accord alors on va commencer
par de calcul et de baptiser poney
calcul 2 x 2500 ce deuxième cas mur
entre parenthèses 67 plus 19 x 1000
entre parenthèses troisième calcul
quel est le triple d'une 205 écoulée
alors on passerait donc de réfléchir
prendre des notes
une mère doit partager six douzaines
d'oeufs de pâques entre huit enfants
combien 2 or à chaque enfant une mère
doit partager six douzaines d'oeufs de
pâques entre huit enfants combien de
haut à chaque enfant
longtemps les personnes tombées dans
l'est la réponse est des neuf 9 e
alors on n'est pas rare d'en partager si
vous êtes deux ou six fois dont deux
s'affrontent ou 70 elle a huit enfants
77 en effet neuf une fois lui ses
soixante dix neuf à ce deuxième problème
un jardin rectangulaire à 25 mètres de
largeur sa longueur est le triple de sa
valeur
quel est son périmètre jardiner un
jardin rectangulaire 25 mètres de
largeur sans longueur des les triples de
sa largeur
quel est son périmètre ce n'est pas la
mousse
donc en fait que java à 25 mètres de
largeur ça vous permet le type de
savères jeu trois fois vainqueur et 61
un homme de 75 a reçu d'argent de 25
mètres vous fait une somme être pour lui
de livrer 200 m le pérou dans une classe
18 enfants portent des lunettes et il y
à 12,6 et la moitié d'entre elles ne
portent pas de lunettes
combien de béances on porte des lunettes
dans cette classe et positionnement 2
pourquoi sa manière pas de stylo a alors
qu'elles sont ils pas de sitôt pour la
question public et donne le double d'une
ce n'est pas maintenant a promis la
finale du marteau
c'est à dire ce soir à paris pendant dix
jours alors qu en france on était
content oui bon maintenant on va passer
niveau cm1 donc on va appeler quentin
lamon et robin ni lui attend quentin ici
voilà donc c'est parti pour la finale
les trois premiers problèmes premier
problème entre parenthèses 15,3 x 3 + 4
2e calcule combien de m il ya des signes
dans tout ce qui le met et 3 des
canettes souci c'est la venue du mans 3e
calcul sans - 8 25 c est bien on va
passer calcul gagnant 23 calcules tu
veux gagner les trois effet 3 3 c'est
pas fini premiers calculs problème des
drogues le tour d'un stade mesure 400 m
jean a effectué quatre tous et demi en
cours en indiquant mètres la distance
qui n'a pas encore eu un deuxième
problème pour la fête du défi lecture
une école va recevoir 125 élèves et dix
accompagnateurs
il y à déjà le triple d'élèves dans
l'école
combien d'élèves y aura-t-il ce jour là
ce sont 500 kw à cérences troisième
problème s'ils vont une pyramide avec 10
briques de 1 kg 75 et six briques de
pain kg 500 combien pèse pyramide un
kilo s'ils vont t'ils ramid avec des
briques d 1 kg 750 et six briques des 20
kg 575
combien pèse la pyramide en kg
on va donner l'explication qui confirme
les petits collègues de 1,75 kg voire 10
soit 20 derrière 61 17 5 kg
ensuite la syrie 1,5 à 6,3 points 59 g
et donc 17,5 kg cheveux noirs
il faut que 26,5 on va faire le bilan
le résultat net intègre elle est là
voilà donc quentin c'est le champion des
vinyles au cm1 nom qui partira également
paris pendant dix jours
alors on va passer maintenant les liens
de la dernière finale de ces deux oscars
et c'est sans charles seuil et citoyen
pour la grande finale tenue paris on va
commencer par les trois calcul
automatisés donc on ne ment pas
notamment remis calcul entre parenthèses
465 crise 37 - entre parenthèses 49 - 36
2e calcul quel est le siège du dixième
de cent vingt
c'est dans ce troisième calcule combien
de minutes
y at-il dans 2400 que brodeur car si ce
n'est pas d'un vrai nous est ici des
galets lisses apprend sur le store le
personnage alors maintenant donc on
passe aux problèmes des notes
premier problème pour ne pas avoir mis
sa ceinture de sécurité
monsieur daniel a reçu une amende de 90
euros
ayant oublié de la payer cette amende
sera majoré de 15%
combien devra-t-il maintenant réglé quoi
ne pas avoir ni ceinture de sécurité
monsieur daniel a reçu une amende de 90
euros
ayant oublié de le payer cette amende
sera majoré de 15%
combien de brad il est maintenant réglé
deuxième problème
pauline a parcouru 800 km avec 40 litres
d'essence il lui reste six libre combien
de kilomètres peut tellement par vaux
rien au lit n'a pas couru huit sentiers
de m avec 410 4 48 d'essence il lui
reste philippe saumont dîner alors
troisième problème
christophe a acheté 8 12 euros de
légumes et un rôti à 15 euros le kilo il
paie avec un billet de 50 euros et le
manche en sûrs en huit euros quelle est
la masse en kilo du rôti classe 10
en dix ans alors charles francis troy
et bien donc voilà notre chance du haut
de ses revenus que c'est à dire donc que
c'est charles qui ira donc en famille
pendant dieu bien un petit bout tâche
allait suivre
donc voilà c'est terminé on a eu trois
champions de ces deux serveurs ces deux
villes est tout fier la voirie
voilà merci beaucoup et à bientôt
à l'année prochaine pour les hommes